各位同仁 各位朋友 大家好
非常高興和大家在線上進行主題分享
這個主題是我們團隊受螞蟻祕宣邀請
共同研發的
在此對螞蟻祕宣的邀請表示感謝
近年來祕宣在行業中的應用
越來越廣泛和重要
螞蟻祕宣也為大家提供了
一系列主題課程
我們此次的主題主要撤充的
不是祕宣的基礎理論
是祕宣在行業實踐中的應用
我們重點選擇了車線領域
來與大家共同探討
祕宣在車線行業中的應用及其前景
我們此次的內容主要包括兩個方面
一是檢要介紹我們在車線的發展
二是探討祕宣技術
在車線領域的應用及其前景
為什麼先介紹一下我們的車線發展呢
這也是螞蟻祕宣邀請我們
共同分享該主題的原因
我們團隊的車線業務
至於國內造成新實力共同成長的
可以說是今天新能源
車線生態的開創者
接下來我簡單介紹一下
我們車線發展的情況
從2018年開始
我們打造的新車線商業模式發展至今
我們和我們的生態夥伴一起
累積實現了百萬台新能源車
幾百億車線寶貝的銷售額
年銷售額最高是超七十億元
我們的工作效果也得到了
同行和客戶行業標更的積極評價
有幾個重要的里程碑
給大家做一下簡單的介紹
2018年我們聯合數家保險中介
共同組成了中介共同體
與某知名主機廠
首創了主機廠品牌車線
推出了以車線為核心的綜合服務包
此後我們持續創新
先後與多家主義上合作
在行業率先研發了免錄單
智能報價 出單平台
在行業率相開創了
車線非車線
非保險產品的核單支付
實施清分及使名人證功能
在行業率先構建了
車線線上雲可服務平台
這些現在都已成為行業的標竿
2024年3月
我們又率先在某頭部新能源主機廠
上線了部分環節的
拒保雲服務機器人
今年全流程的拒保雲服務機器人
也開始進行了試點
通過多年的沉澱
我們搭建了這個油主機廠
保險公司 服務公司
消經公司 支付公司
科技公司 客服公司
保險中介共同體
共同組成的車線運營體系和生態
滿足了主機廠 經銷商
員工車 社會車 商用車
不同場景的車線需求
總之我們只在通過
科技加運營
構建以品牌保險為核心的
車生態綜合服務
並拖互聯網視為持續驅動
車主用戶的體驗升級
接下來
我們將聚焦此次的重點內容
與大家共同探討
密旋在車線行業中的應用
及其前景
通過剛才我們車線發展的介紹
大家可以看到
我們在構建車線生態服務機器中
觀念了眾多的參與局主體
加之信息化 智能化 平台化的要求
使得數據交互成為關鍵的支撐
因此數據安全 個人信息保護
數據商業價值與商業機密問題
均需審慎對待
我們也可以看到
國家層面出台了
數據安全法 個人信息保護法
網絡數據安全管理條例
以及在行業層面
也出台了
銀行保險機構數據安全管理辦法等等
一方面對數據安全和信息保護
提出了更高的要求
另一方面建立了技術合規導向
明確要求金融行業應採用
影視增強技術保護數據的安全
密旋技術
比方說大家數字的聯邦學習
安全多方計算 同胎加密
實行環境等
在保護數據影視的前提下
實現協同計算
既能避免敏感信息洩露
又能融合各方數據優勢
產生多維高價值數據
密旋技術勢在必行在行業
密旋技術勢必在行業中
得到廣泛應用
我個人認為
在保險行業中健康險
車險包括設車的非車險
將是未來應用密旋
作為廣泛和深刻的兩大險種
為什麼這麼說
我們先來看看
車險生態的數據維度
一方面行業各大保設
基本都實現了
基於用戶及車輛
風險平級的自主折扣細數的調整
我們可以目前是
為有限的自主定價
另一方面新能源新技術
包括自價的興起
驅動產品創新
理賠及運營服務手段的提升
而這些都是依托
與數據支撐的技術創新
數據員設計車企
保險公司
以及眾多的第三方服務公司
可以說是主體廣泛
維度眾多
我認為可以將這些數據
封為六大類
第一個就是車輛及用戶數據
包括就是
這裡用戶主要是指
車輛的我認為可以封為六大類
第一大類是車輛及用戶數據
那麼用戶主要指
車輛的實際價值者
第二類我們可以定義為
車輛數據
包括車輛的基本信息
經營屬性車況的
第三類是行駛數據
包括駕駛行為
行駛場景及其環境
里程 回賬尾巴記錄的
第四類是投保數據
第五類是理賠維修數據
第六類是車後生活數據
包括保養 洗車 代步代價
加油 充電 導航等等
那麼這些數據
共同構成了車輛
全生命週期的畫像
用好這些數據
商業價值巨大
社會以深遠
而如何用好
而如何安全有效
並高效地運用
那我覺得
密選技術
將是一把關鍵的鑰匙
如前所需
密選技術
可以根據項目的需求
實現數據可用不可見
為多方數據協作
提供安全體作
其核心價值在於
協作各方通過
數據不動 模型動
數據加密可計算的特徵
既滿足一方對數據的需求
又保護另一方
用戶隱私與商業機密
同時可以說是
符合個人信息保護法
數據安全法中
數據最小化
與安全協作的要求
最終實現數據流通不洩露
業務協作不降效
回到我們車線生態
我們可以看到左側
各類數據通過密選技術
進行數據處理
實現多元數據的融合
進而支撐模型的搭建
女實際應用
來滿足右側
各項功能和應用
接下來我們也選取
三個場景
共同探討密選
在車線行業中的應用
首先要選取一個
大家作為熟悉
且曾經非常熱門的話題
就是車線的風險
評分與定價
依主機場
也就是車企和保險公司
為例
那麼保險公司
通過投保
它一般會掌握
用戶的靜態因子
比方說用戶信息也好
車輛信息也好
那麼除機場
也就是車企
它往往會擁有動態因子
比方說駕駛行為數據
這裡面包括
即駕駛 即煞車頻率等等
同時也有行駛場景數據
比方說夜間駕駛比例等等
那麼保險公司
其實它是希望結合靜態因子
和動態因子
進行更精準的風險評期
從而來
測定事故
概率進行預測
但動態因子
涉及主機場的用戶隱私
無法直接提供
那麼在密選方面
我們可以
就是選擇兩種密選方案
進行參考
比方說第一種
我們統態加密
主機場加密動態因子數據
保險公司直接使用加密數據
計算風險評級
再結合自身的競選模型
從而生存保費
這是一種方式
那麼也可以用聯邦學習
雙方在本地
用各自的數據
比方說保險公司
它用歷史保費
和理賠關聯數據
主機場這邊是駕駛行為數據
來訓練駕駛行為
和風險印色模型
僅共享模型參數
保險公司最終
基於聯合模型
從而進行定價
那麼對於保險公司來說
它可以獲得精準定價的依據
來細化定價模型
從而實現
基於人和里程的UBI車線
那麼對於車主來說
主機場無需暴露
用戶隱私信息
從而實現
用戶就車主享受
個性化的保費及其服務
那麼對於車企
主機場來說
它也可以提供
類UBI的服務
比方說
提供安全駕駛積分
同時它也可以結合數據優化
結合數據來優化
車輛操作反饋
比方說
為頻繁及煞車的用戶
提供煞車輔助提醒
或者是針對特殊場景
來優化安全配置
比方說
為山區道路用戶
來推送
躲破緩降的功能
這是我們密宣
在車線風險評分
與車線定價裏面的應用
這個是大家相對來說比較熟悉的
也是目前
有很多的保險公司
和科技公司都在
為車線的風險評分
與車線定價方面
提供這方面的服務
是大家相對來說
很熟悉的
已經得到了廣泛的應用
那麼第二個
我想跟大家一起來探討的就是
密宣在飛車線
產品窗息裏面的應用
那這裏的飛車線
主要是跟車相關的
一個是設車的
跟車高度相關的
比方說我們鹽包
自駕電池等等類的
第二個是
車相關的
場景化的一些飛車線
比方說是自駕
天氣線
醫療線
包括
開車可能去參加各種運動
包括的運動線
那麼密宣
也是在這些產品裏面
可以得到廣泛的應用
接下來可能舉兩個例子
一個是
前段時間
大家都比較
市場比較熱的自駕保險
第二個是
我們在實際場景中
曾經碰到的一個
現實需求
就是電池的飛線上損失
這樣一個場景
那麼首先回到我們的
駕保險裏面來
我覺得
密宣在駕乘保險裏面的應用
更多的
都不是說在
就是
保費定價方面的應用
能夠
能夠推動自駕保險
在前段時間
得以面向市場
能夠做成這樣一個
產品的上市
那麼更重要的是
依賴於
密宣在保險責任
和判定方面的價值
那麼對
就是主機場來說
它掌握了
實施全幹期的原始數據
包括
自動駕駛系統操作日治的
那麼主機場可以把這些數據
加密後進上傳
保險公司使用加密數據
根據保險責任
和聽判定規則來進行計算
判定它是否屬於
自駕導致的保險責任
那麼這個功能的實現
就為自駕保險的順理推出
起到了積極的作用
所以說
自駕保險
能夠在前段時間
得以在市場上廣泛的應用
其實也是
就是數據技術方面
接下來我們
就密宣在
飛車線產品創新方面的應用
跟大家做一些分享
那麼這裡說的飛車線
主要是跟車
相關的飛車線
第一個是設車類的飛車線
比如說鹽保也好
電池也好 自駕也好
第二個是
我們車的使用場景中的
各種飛車線
包括自駕的預先線
天氣線
比如說開車去進行
各項運動的時候
可能衍生出來的
一些運動保險
那麼這裡要選取兩個
產品跟大家
進行一些分享
一個是前期
也是非常熱門的一個選總
就是自駕保險
那麼自駕保險的推出
我覺得
密宣在它的應用裡面
最重要的都不是在定價方面
通過保險公司
和主機上的數據
在定價方面的應用
更多的是在責任判定方面
那麼主機上來說
它掌握了
知識的全看器的原始數據
包括自動駕駛系統的
操作日子
然後主機場
可以將這些加密數據進行上傳
保險公司使用加密數據
根據保險規則
和責任判定規則
進行計算
來判定是否屬於保險責任
這也為自駕保險
能夠順利的推出
提到了機器的作用
第二個想跟大家分享的產品
是我們在實際過程中
曾經碰到的一個需求
就是電池的飛線上損失
補償保險
那麼大家都知道
新的原車電池
很多都在車輛的底部
經常會發生
寡乘和碰撞的事故
當時可能沒有造成
直接的損失
或者是損失比較小
沒有造成電池的
性能的急劇下降
導致意外事故的發生
接下來跟大家
第二個想跟大家分享的
是我們在實際過程中
以前碰到的一個需求
就是電池的飛線上損失
這樣一個場景
大家都知道新的原車電池
往往都在車輛的底部
事實上會發生
寡乘和碰撞的事故
當時可能沒有造成
明顯的電池的受損
和性能的衰減
但是過段時間之後
出現了電池性能的衰減
出現了需要賠償的事故
那麼再去找
保險公司的車線進行理賠的時候
就會發生
一個找不到事故的現場
第二個責任的判定
也是不很好界定
那麼騎士主機場
它是掌握了電池
實施全感器的原始數據
包括電池性能的數據的
那麼履產可以將這些數據
加密後進商權
保險公司同樣使用加密數據
根據自己的保險責任
和判定規則進行計算
來判定是否屬於保險責任
那麼剛才分享的這兩個方面
都是密宣在
反正就是
都是數據通過密宣
在責任判定方面的應用
其實之前我們也瞭解到
數據的維度很多
然後主機場掌握的數據
也非常豐富
如果能夠將更多的數據應用起來
我們覺得那麼
在製程飛車線產品創新方面
我們可以將這些數據
通過加密集權之後
能夠不僅僅是幫助
剛說的責任的判定
也可以幫助來定價
封控 理賠
等多方面的應用
讓我們的飛車線
能夠開發更多的飛車線
進行創新
提供更多的技術保障和支持
那麼第三個想跟大家介紹的就是
密宣在
正能理賠和減省方面的應用
大家可以看到
在數據方面
其實主機場是掌握了
車輛的故障日誌的
包括比方說
全感器記錄的碰撞時間
過漲發生時序
那麼對保險公司來說
它也掌握了事故的報案信息
因為出現之後
會有報案人員進行報案
那麼這兩方的數據
對於就是數據來說
這兩方的數據來說
其實都是敏感數據
主機場的數據
不僅涉及到技術機密
涉及到用戶隱私
那麼保險公司的數據
更多的是涉及到用戶的隱私
那麼如何把這兩方的數據
結合起來
能夠幫助保險公司
進行責任的判定
那麼我們這裡
也可以表說舉個例子
表說採用
安全多放計權的方式
那麼雙方構建
責任判定協議
主機場按協議
上傳加密的故障發生時間
全感器一場之等等的信息
保險公司上傳
事故報案時間
損失情況
還有它的責任
判定規則等信息
那麼通過
安全多放計算協議
聯合計算故障
與事故的關聯性評分
比方說時間差
是否在於之內
全感器一場
是否匹配碰撞
緊輸出是否
還是不屬於保險責任的
最終結果
那麼這樣從而提升
你陪和省的效率
它不需人工來進行合驗
同時保護雙方的數據機密
同理我們也可以用在
保險反欺詐方面
識別虛假報案與騙保
也可以通過
密宣技術融合
同理
我們也可以用在
保險欺詐方面
來識別虛假報案與騙配
通過密宣技術
融合主機場與保險公司的數據
經模型集權來進行分析和判斷
這些都可以為我們保險公司
在理陪和檢測方面進行
起到很好的作用
那麼總結上述應用分析
採用密宣技術對接
車企與保師能夠在
保護隱私前提下
將駕駛行為
車輛狀況
場景環境等數據
與風險定價
理陪風控等需求深度結合
最終實現
對於保險公司來說
車險定價更精準
理陪更高效
對於車企來說
它可以用戶服務更個性化
車輛安全設計
更貼合實際需求
對於用戶來說
就是車主來說
獲得公平的保費和更安全的
對於車主來說
對於用戶來說
可以獲得更公平的保費
和安全的駕駛體驗
這些數據協同
將是未來
車險市場化
智能化的核心方向
這些數據協同
將是未來
車險市場化
智能化的核心方向
以上分享是基於
我們自身的實踐
和對行業的人知
希望能為大家帶來啟發
分享中如有不足之處
也請各位包含諒解
再次感謝大家
同時中心感謝
螞蟻彌勸
提供此時分享機會
謝謝大家